we have to begin with some breaking news
overnight it's not good there was
another another deadly shooting gun
violence in america this time a gunman
killed at least two people at a safeway
grocery store now we know that he used
an ar-15 style weapon and the attack
began in the store's parking lot this
happened in bend oregon in the central
part of the state jonathan bigliotti is
following all of this for us now
jonathan good morning to you
and gail good morning to you police say
they received a call about an active
shooter around 7pm local time last night
when they got to the scene they said the
shooter was dead this morning we're
hearing from a grocery store employee
who hid in a walk-in fridge during the
shooting and a neighbor who described
hearing multiple rounds of shots fired
there were
10 to 20 shots
and then another 10 to 20 shots heather
thompson was sitting on her parents
porch when she heard dozens of gunshots
coming from the forum shopping center in
bend oregon sunday night people were
running out of safeway spurts of shot
maybe two four and then it stopped
police say the shooter walked over from
a nearby neighborhood and started firing
in the parking lot appearing to hit the
door of this big lot the shooter moved
through the parking lot
from the costco on the west end
shooting rounds from an ar-15 style
rifle the gunman then went to a safeway
in the shopping center police say he
shot one person at the entrance and
continued firing inside shooting a
second person both victims died shoppers
and employees ran and hid me and three
other employees ran into a walk-in
refrigerator and close the door and stay
there we stayed hidden until the
authorities arrived bend police chief
mike krantz says officers heard gunfire
coming from the safeway when they
arrived when they got inside they said
they found the apparent shooter dead
with bullet casings the ar-15 style
rifle and a shotgun nearby he said
officers never fired their weapons our
hearts got to the victims and the
families in this incident and we know
that this is a frightening thing for our
community
and police have not released the
identity of the victims or the suspect
we also don't know the motive they say
the investigation is just beginning this
morning john
jonathan thank you